on a reçu la vidéo d'une personne qui a
fait partie de la vie d'un chroniqueur
alors regardez regardez cette place à y
sert il je m'appelle port lay ce que
j'aimerais c'est reprendre contact avec
quelqu'un qui travaille avec toi c'est
un chant mines chroniqueur avec qui je
passe à un moment de ma vie ça me ferait
tellement plaisir
merci merci by vous demande d'accueillir
pearl et crawford qui sont le soir pour
les bons soirs pour les alors du ou des
micro merci d'être avec nous peu relais
ça va parler
vous avez connu un des chroniqueurs ici
ce soir
est ce que c'est une personne
ils vont y vante vivante une personne de
plus de 40 ans personne qui oui donc ce
n'est pas maxime non non est ce que
cette personne
on va aller un petit peu vite mesure
plus d'un mètre cinquante
non je pense que oui ta merde plus d'un
mètre soixante bon fabien way connaissez
parlait pas bon je vous le dis ce que
pelé newcastle vous avez été modèle et
actrice dans la série gossip girl
seventies vous avez connu fabien sous le
pseudo de gypsy fabien couverture du
magazine hot club on dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce que vous vous rappelez de
parler de visage comme ça pour jouer
vous jouez quoi de visages ça me dit
rien parce qu'en fait on voyait pas bien
et on va se parler
c'était en 77 ha ouais les photos alors
on a changé la face au cper laissez-vous
sako déborde elle est magnifique
oui c'est vous parlé avec mon père oui
je sais pas j'avais pas cette tête là
mais si bas si ça ressemble
vous êtes sûr c'est un saut dit non non
non ses villes ses potes c'est what non
c'est une clause sur la photo c'est moi
oui mais voilà alors c'est vous ouais
vous rappeler le type si physiquement
non mais vous avez une frange à l'époque
c'est ça la force par le foie et vous
aviez dit oui voilà alors joly va bien
bah oui oui montrez-vous peut-être qu'à
bordeaux on en parle et vous êtes
magnifique
vous êtes prêt et mec même moi j'ai fait
une connerie ou c'est vrai si soir c'est
fait quoi vraiment ya un fossé non
excusez-moi ont réagi parce qu'ils ont
voulu me payer en fait c'est une vraie
personne ou pas et donc c'est là que
j'ai apporté les couvertures mais c'est
pas c'est pas un photomontage sa terre
ça me convient pas l'air et fabien vous
avez vraiment fait une photo avec paris
j'ai fait 117 couvent alors je le
problème c'est qu'ils accueillent en
effet sont la vraie bord duquel on est
au près bon merci et c'était ça la vanne
en fait
c'est quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faites vos petits bisous elle est belle
[Applaudissements]
oui ce qui s'est passé c'est fabien à
part le s max et fabien il est beau
c'est un bâton au numéro mais quelle son
numéro mais va pas donner son numéro à
l'antenne non non non pas son numéro de
téléphone non mais on est on est on
avait des numéros en fait là il décode
de la duchesse la duchesse a b c est
quoi toi non non je dois pas comment je
m'appelais m'a dit s'ils arrêtent gipsy
non parce que le jeu ben je vous laisse
repartir tous les deux d'accord allez-y
faites vous plaisir merci merci et bravo
et merci est très jolie elle est restée
enfin le caribéen c'est incroyable un c
ur
[Rires]